[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous alors quoi de
beau ce week-end samedi c'est la journée
de la danse dimanche c'est la journée du
jazz aujourd'hui je suis accompagné
Mathis stagiaire pupitre
l'honneur de cette journée du jazz je
vais interpréter une musique je vais
interpréter du film là-haut parce que
j'aime bien ce film
[Musique]
attends plus haut là j'arrive pas à bien
voir
plus comme ça là
[Musique]
devant le visage comme ça je suis pas
perturbé
[Musique]
merci de m'avoir écouté j'espère que ma
prestation vous a plu maintenant on va
passer au micro-trottoir
on va passer au micro-trottoir et savoir
si vous aimez le jazz et si vous
connaissez quelques petits pas de danse
c'est parti
est-ce que vous vous écoutez un peu de
musique madame dites moi d'abord qui
vous êtes je suis Thomas fetcherche
présente la météo du week-end tous les
week-ends
Maiden tout ce qui bouge quoi
mon conseillerais un là c'est lequel je
sais pas j'ai pas encore écouté
est-ce que vous dansez un peu plus
maintenant non danser non ça c'était à
l'époque de ma jeunesse on y est
et de l'investissement ok ah oui pas mal
du tout
[Applaudissements]
je suis un peu plus loin
c'est très bien vous
mais vous pouvez pas faire la danse des
escalopes
[Rires]
OK
et tu le trouves comment franchement tu
peux le dire il y a pas la caméra
en plus ça c'est par contre désolé mais
c'est vrai et bah il faudrait que tu
apprennes un peu plus dedans parce que
là comme ça
peut-être parce que moi je l'ai pas du
tout c'est comme ça que j'ai
apprises
merci pour tous ces mouvements deuxième
leçon la semaine prochaine OK
[Musique]